bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got brad
back
from unstoppable domains thank you so
much for doing this
thanks for having me for sure let's just
remind people
uh unstoppable domains you guys are
essentially creating human readable
domains but you explain it way better
than i do so just what is
unstoppable domain's mission uh and kind
of what have you guys built so far
yeah so we build domains on blockchains
we believe that users should be in
control on the internet
uh not companies and that starts with
your domain
uh which is like your identity online so
you control your domain
it's a nft stored inside of your wallet
just like cryptocurrency nobody can take
it
away from you nobody can move it around
nobody can make updates to it
other than you very different than a
traditional domain name which is stored
by godaddy godaddy can take it away from
you
godaddy can get hacked go daddy can get
tricked and somebody else can be
making updates or changing it or doing
something else
and what's what's cool about blockchain
domains as opposed to regular domains
they have all of these different use
cases
one that is close to my heart and close
to the uh the crypto community's heart
uh is that it's kind of like a
decentralized venmo you can send me
money to brad.crypto
you can send me bitcoin or ether or any
other cryptocurrency and you can check
out my website at brad.crypto
same domain does both things we'll do
many more things in the future
about 700 000 of these have been
registered so far we've been at it for a
couple of years
uh and yeah so one of the things that uh
just immediately jumps to mind and we
talked about it in prior episodes that
you've been on
uh is this idea that uh the wallet
addresses uh are really
you know confusing they're long strings
of letters and numbers uh very similar
to what i p addresses used to be where
people would have to type in you know
one two one dot one zero dot you know
seven four six whatever
and then when somebody came up with
human readable so i could just type in
www.google.com
that made the internet much much more
usable uh much more user friendly and
obviously
led to an explosion of uh of various
types of products and companies that
were built on the internet
uh you guys are essentially doing the
exact same thing here uh but
it really serves two purposes one is for
wallet so i can send money to you know
pom.crypto
uh or it can serve as a domain name um
but
i know that recently you guys uh
announced this
brand new uh partnership with uh with
opera
uh so maybe let's just start kind of
with like what is opera
uh and why do most people not know what
that is
so opera browser is is actually one of
the top five browsers in the
in the world it's just not as popular in
the us now there was a period of time i
think
uh maybe 10 years ago where techies in
the us were really
uh really into it but uh they have kind
of uh they have kind of moved to other
browsers but
in europe it's extremely popular around
the world is extremely popular i believe
it's the most popular browser in nigeria
now
which is also one of the top countries
for crypto so i think there's
potentially uh potentially a link there
opera browser has leaned extremely
heavily into crypto and i think
all essentially all of the browsers uh
that are not owned by giant trillion
dollar companies
are looking deeply at crypto right now
uh and that's just something that's just
uh that should be on the entire crypto
community's radar that the browser
community is looking really closely at
our space building wallets
uh trying to get into the crypto
business any number of ways
opera has been doing that for the past
couple of years they've been on the
forefront
and uh now they're uh now they're going
deeper and what deeper looks like is
you can now resolve
crypto websites uh inside of all of
opera browser's properties so this is
over 300 million internet users that can
now just
type into crypto and it works just like
dot com uh it also works for the payment
use case but this is um
this is kind of a kind of a big deal for
uh for decentralized websites
yeah when i was at facebook in 2014 2015
uh we used to make uh fairly like simple
changes
uh to the user experience whether it was
just you know shortening the number of
clicks it took to do an activity
uh making something a little bit more uh
easily accessible or visible
uh and there would be these massive
increases in usage on the opera browser
specifically
some of that i think was due to kind of
older versions of phones
um and you know people weren't walking
around with an iphone but also some of
it was just
the sheer size of the audience right and
so
uh i think you've said that one-tenth of
all internet users
use the opera browser is that accurate
yeah it's like so i think the published
number is a little over 300 million so i
don't know the exact number of current
internet users but i think it's pretty
close to 110
yeah and so when you think about uh kind
of the importance for crypto is there a
thought process here that like the
emerging countries
uh and developing countries are actually
better suited to adopt
uh these types of technologies so that's
a better place to uh to focus on
or what really kind of drove the the
idea between uh
going and doing this partnership with
opera you know i think that there's a
lot of opportunity around the world
us as a company you know we're a san
francisco-based tech company it's just
easier for us to operate in u.s and
europe so that is
kind of where we've been focusing but
that's mostly because of language most
of us are english speakers and so it's
hard for us to
market in other languages not because
there's not amazing opportunities there
so opera browser for us is is probably
mostly about the the european market and
there's of course other
other uh other things that we're working
on that are going to be directly
impacting the us market in terms of uh
in terms of browsers
um so that's been our focus um but
there's there's a ton of opportunity
there and i'm sure
we're going to get there eventually as
we uh as we continue to grow
yeah and so it will people be able to
use the domains for the exact same
things that they can use on other
browsers in the opera browser are there
any sort of obstacles
uh to the the full usage of the product
no ifs ands or buds no change this
setting
no make this update you just do what you
would normally
tell somebody what you would normally
tell them about a website hey go check
out my website
and what's so fascinating what's
fascinating to me about this
is uh in the kind of western developed
world you still have to go to
uh a web 3 experience or some kind of
the decentralized web in some cases
here if this is the default browser for
you know again
a tenth of the internet's users in a lot
of these countries now
by proxy uh unstoppable domains
essentially becomes the default domain
system that they could use
if you continue to see penetration of
the markets right
absolutely and it's the thought process
that
um people will choose unstoppable
domains
uh utilized via the opera browser
overcome the traditional domain system
simply from censorship resistance and
some of the benefits that we previously
talked about
i think it's more about consumers having
control
of what they're doing online so it might
not necessarily be that you're concerned
about being censored it's that you're
concerned
about you having complete ownership
because
all around the world we have these these
registrars that have all these kind of
crazy laws and regulations and you know
they get
they the the amount of hacking that
happens amongst these registrars around
the world would
would shock people i mentioned godaddy
probably earlier godaddy had a big hack
in november
of 2020 and that's probably the most one
of the most secure domain name
registrars in the world so
there's just all kinds of problems baked
into this
baked into this world but the other
thing is is that you just can't
you can't prove anything about the user
because of this security problem because
you have this custodian like you don't
know a hundred percent that the the web
content that you're looking at
is presented to you by the person that
you were intending to go and to go and
see
so i think blockchains in general like
their superpower
is about verification like you know 100
certain things about what you're looking
at what you're using who you're
interacting with etc
yeah it's uh it's absolutely fascinating
another thing that you guys have done
recently
is you've basically empowered the
ability for people to use their
uh dot crypto domains to create these
like nft galleries and you've shown me a
couple of them and they're pretty damn
cool
explain what the thought process here
was and what the actual technology
allows somebody to do
so i think it all comes back to this
idea of verification so
i've got brad.crypto i've got a bunch of
nfts in my wallet
and we built this feature that allows
you to generate a website on ipfs a
decentralized website takes a couple of
clicks
super easy you can do it right now and
you can go and see my collection so the
app
what it does is it goes and looks inside
my wallet finds the nfts that i own and
displays that
as an art gallery and i've got one up
right now at brad.crypto
and what you know it is when you're
looking at brad.crypto
you know that the owner of the domain is
also the owner of those specific assets
and that's something that you don't get
with web2 that's something you don't get
with the traditional web is that you
don't have
any assurances about the content that
you're looking at and so
in this new internet world what i'm
going to do is i'm going to go around on
the internet
and i'm going to flex i'm going to say
here are the things that i own
they're digital sets here are the things
that i own and i'm going to be able to
prove to you 100
yeah these are actually mine it's not
just
pictures it's not just copies uh
i'm not somebody standing in i'm not a
fake identity i am the person that owns
this stuff
um and i think that's the that's the
secret superpower
uh of the decentralized web uh that i
think everyone should be focusing on
and how much of this is gonna be
dependent on you guys building out kind
of
uh functionality um or some of this
kind of auto generation versus users can
do that themselves right like
could somebody have gone and done this
before you guys added the functionality
on the nft gallery
uh using their own crypto domain or is
it something where you guys
you know as you kind of push forward
you'll continue to launch more and more
functionality and it'll just make
uh the dot crypto and the unstoppable
domains much more attractive to people
it's all open source anybody can build
whatever they want people have built
their own versions i've seen like
virtual galleries that are like in vr
where you can go and check out people's
art see all kinds of cool stuff
the problem i mean most of that stuff's
not commercial ready so what
what what our goal has been with all
this stuff is that we want to see the
market like we've got
and we've been sitting around you know
jamming on ideas
for how this stuff could work you know
over the past couple of years
and we just want to show people some
examples to inspire and get people
kind of get the get the wheel turning
but ultimately like the work is going to
be done
by thousands and thousands of web
developers just like with
just like with the traditional web like
we're not we're not a web company
you know our our goal is domain names
and this is really just a way to
to kind of get the creative juices
flowing yeah
what's been the most surprising thing to
you uh both from the opera launch
and also um the nft galleries is there
anything that just kind of blew you away
or
or was something you weren't expecting
but it's pretty cool
people are obsessed uh
with this uh with with the art that they
own
and i i have not personally been you
know gone super deep into
it into art it's something that i've had
friends and family that were
you know big fans and they've kind of uh
evangelized it and tried
to to get me excited and i i i get it
and i appreciate it and i get involved
but
uh i have just the amount of
uh emotional energy that it can
grab from people like i've seen just
with some of these galleries i mean i've
seen people sit there and study
a single gallery for 15 or 20 minutes
and like that
that's a lot of time on site you know if
you're if you're building if you built a
website and you get somebody to stay
there for 15 minutes
that's not bad on the internet you know
i think average time is like 10 seconds
or something like that
so just the the addictiveness
of of seeing this stuff has been
probably the
the most surprising part to me i think
the second part and this is kind of like
the macro
crypto part is how deep browsers want to
go into crypto
like and this is just something i can't
emphasize enough like these
companies are looking for a path forward
and they see crypto
as a core strategy for them whether
that's you know building a wallet and
enabling financial services
and these companies have tons of users
like you you add a zero or add two zeros
on a crypto app
um these are not necessarily your native
crypto users these are just internet
users
but there's so many people in these
companies and these companies have
really low margins so they're saying we
have this
super active user base uh they have all
these issues on the internet
uh crypto can help solve them let's go
add a wallet and then all of a sudden we
can enable all this stuff
uh opera is an example of that brave is
an example of that uh and i think we're
gonna see more of that and that
that piece right there um is just like i
mean
that's just another just massive massive
community
uh that the crypto world is onboarding
and has been onboarding over the past
year or two and it's just one of the
many uh massive onboarding waves that
we're seeing in crypto
yeah what's fascinating to me about this
entire thing
is uh you get what most people would
have thought as kind of legacy
infrastructure
that is still run by technologists and
the technologists understand the
benefits of the
uh technology stack that's being built
in crypto and they're starting to say
hey how can i incorporate this into that
legacy product and so the opera browser
is actually
a fantastic uh kind of example of this
where they've got the built-in user base
they've got distribution
they understand that they've got
centralized infrastructure
and they've got some kind of failure
points along the way and if they start
to actually
uh replace it with decentralized type
infrastructure or crypto infrastructure
you can really actually kind of
supercharge your legacy business
and adapt and thrive in this new world
rather than simply sit there take it on
the chin and be disrupted
and they're all they're all looking at
chrome and
these giant companies and those
companies aren't innovating like those
companies don't care about their browser
business
their browser business is not that's not
where they that's not where they make
their money so
there's not any reason for the large
incumbents to
uh to go and innovate and then there's
this massive
massive you know new you know web3
oriented crypto oriented
uh user base that is looking for tools
and a browser is just a very natural
place like
if you're thinking about like where to
store your assets uh maybe even where to
store your domain so you can be using it
for various things online like that's a
very natural
natural place so like having money
inside of your browser
is kind of a no-brainer for users and
that's something that was
just started being enabled over the past
couple of years
and that's that's your wallet following
you around on the internet all in one
application so it's
when you think about it that way it it
it feels somewhat inevitable that those
things would come together
um but uh but now it's kind of finally
you know out there in the market and you
can play with it
yeah the other part that i think is so
fascinating is when you integrate a lot
of this crypto infrastructure in with
legacy products
uh and it's done in a thoughtful way uh
now all the user doesn't necessarily
have to go
uh kind of be indoctrinated into crypto
infrastructure they don't have to go
do a lot of kind of the nuanced stuff
that uh makes the user experience and
adoption
uh more difficult or has more friction
you basically are getting them to
onboard onto the infrastructure but
they're doing it through a user
interface that they're
very familiar with they may not even
know that anything's changed and
therefore you can drastically increase
adoption
at a much faster pace right
absolutely yeah um all right what uh
what do you want people to know or or
what should people go do now that
you guys have this opera integration and
you have the nft gallery
uh well first of all you should go check
it out go check you can go check out
brad.crypto as a starting point but
there's of course tons of
tons of other websites out there mine's
nothing special
um but you should go but you should go
check out uh check out
there's a bunch of new websites coming
out we'll be posting about them
um and go launch your own it's like it's
like three clicks
um all you gotta do is have your domain
in the same
same wallet as your nftr collection and
then
boom click click and you're live i love
it
listen you guys are uh continue to push
the pace of innovation i think that uh
human readable domains obviously uh are
a huge leap forward so please keep it up
uh because i think that you guys can
help on board uh literally hundreds of
millions of new users to
this ecosystem by simply just making it
easier to use the infrastructure so
uh i've been uh cheering you guys on
from the sideline for a while i will
continue to do that and
appreciate you coming on where can
people go and follow you
uh or learn more about unstoppable
domains yeah go check out
unstoppable web on twitter that's a good
place to follow whatever's going on and
also check out unstoppabledomains.com
awesome brad listen thank you so much
for doing this watch it again in the
future
thanks a lot